[Musique]
sur les hauteurs du guillaume saint paul
c'est une récolte particulière qui se
prépare j'organise taristas et son
équipe sont dans les champs pour
cueillir les salades bret des betteraves
tous ces légumes sont bio un choix de
production respectueux de
l'environnement et de la biodiversité a
sûrement bio depuis maintenant deux ans
que nous et il nous fait principalement
bret plus avoir été de braid salade de
betteraves et chouf ouchouf leur bolide
la pomme de terre gamme c'est justement
travaillé vraiment les produits locaux
bio ce bien sûr certifiés bio ici à
l'arrêt comme près de 330 exploitant la
réunion j'organise est certifiée
agriculture biologique
sur ces trois hectares il produit
principalement des légumes
la récolte d'aujourd'hui n'ira pas sur
les marchés elles sera au menu de la
restauration scolaire du collège titan
au port c'est pourquoi demain la
livraison au collège titan les
cuisiniers sont fin prêts la livraison
du jour est soigneusement lavées découpé
et prête à cuisiner une équipe motivée
pas peu fier de travailler les produits
locaux et bio quand on réceptionne des
carottes bio radio salades et concombres
plus citrouille bio et chouchou pour la
profession
menus bio de demain oui le bio important
bonne ça fait marcher l'économie locale
c'est ça qui compte
pour la troisième année consécutive le
collège titan organise une journée
éducative baptisé du champ à l'assiette
les élèves rencontrent les agriculteurs
biologiques et échanges sur les modes de
production
une manière de les sensibiliser sur leur
alimentation les bonnes tous âges pays
qui aujourd'hui sont présents et on
montre leur travail expliquent leur
travail non le cuisine ce midi le menu
proposé est réalisé à partir de produits
biologiques de la règne une réussite
pour les producteurs l'équipe éducative
et surtout pour ces collégiens
ries est un peu de
voir et
très différents
c'est l'année du
est-ce que tu sont différents
[Musique]
mais que
c'est un produit de qualité puisqu'il
n'y a pas de faille à un boucher a gelé
cette action devrait prendre de
l'ampleur dans les années à venir
la loi et galim prévoit d'atteindre
d'ici 2025 et 2030 la part de 20% pour
les produits biologiques dans la
restauration collective
[Musique]